you can get some exercise and support
people living with bleeding disorders
here in nevada the bike senior blood
fundraiser is happening next weekend
the ride benefits the nevada chapter of
the national hemophilia foundation
we spoke to gio pernuti who's become an
avid cyclist he was born with hemophilia
and suffered a lot of injuries growing
up
i had had so many injuries and bleeds
into
my right ankle that i developed
arthritis really bad arthritis
to the point where there was like no
cartilage left in my ankle so it's bone
on bone
yeah how painful he said he could barely
get up a flight of stairs
so he had ankle fusion surgery and was
able to pick up cycling
since then he has done 20 mile marathons
he's even done a duathlon
it's kind of like my outlet if that
makes sense
i'm able to get out on the road whenever
i really want to
and just kind of concentrate on that one
thing you kind of leave
all your other problems behind so the
fundraiser is coming up next saturday
the 21st
it is virtual this year so you can bike
anywhere even on a stationary bike in
your house or a gym
proceeds benefit the local chapter and
there's some cool swag you get too so
we'll put a link
it is on our website right now it's
8newsnow.com